good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast stand happy
this one gets like a little extra
vibrato because not only is it a Friday
it's a Friday before a [__]
holiday weekend [__] Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday get down Friday fun fun
fun looking forward to July 4th weekend
beautiful way to Usher us into the
weekend turdy Lou Who turdy loose screw
turdy how are you
I'm darn good I can't lie Jax it's
Friday this has been was it a long week
I don't know when did the Week begin
when did the week
such a good question why I feel like we
didn't have a show on Monday no we did I
believe it was a Audio Only oh okay this
whole like these last two weeks have
kind of just been like a jumble I feel
hodgepodge after July 4th week we'll get
on more solid footing like we have 30th
birthday we have a couple of like you
know
four weeks and right now it's just it's
just summer Tings tardy you're that
summer break
Trails it's crazy that it's the last day
of June
oh my God anything you want to say to
June before she departs yeah bye June is
a nice month
it is because you know it's really not
so hot yet even though the weather has
been crap in New York between like the
California wildfire like Smokey air this
like surge of rain and humidity we've
had over the last two weeks the weather
has been crap but I think June in
general it's like a nice welcome to
Summer it's like half summer half spring
it's nice yeah
it is nice it's a short month it's a 30
day or
oh is it April June had November exactly
the weather has been I find nice aside
from like the smog and all that jazz
like it's not been very warm and it's
been kind of cool and nice not to be
like the rudest [__] on the planet but
like how the hell would you know you're
on bed rest wow well I checked the
temperature every day to see what baby
Harry needs to wear yeah but like you
aren't feeling it you're not out in the
streets like getting trouble no but I'm
seeing every day it's in the 70s every
day I know but it feels different and
every day we go for like sweatpants and
a t-shirt
well baby Harry is so stylish and the
thing about baby Harry is like he could
be dressed you know inappropriately like
for the wrong weather and he wouldn't
let it get in the way of his fun like
for Harry fun is the number one priority
whether he's wearing shorts whether he's
wearing pants whether he's wearing the
cutest gift that I just got for him that
I ordered in the wrong [__] size
because I'm so dumb and stupid and ugly
well well I know that your gift
didn't go farther away yeah your gift
flopped
um but it was so thoughtful you guys I
thought it was so thoughtful and it
feels like we got a gift I got it from
shoploocombs.com you know ever since his
wife Nicole like took over their you
know merch design marketing she started
making the cutest stuff and she's been
doing it for a while I don't know why
I'm talking about like it's new but she
does a lot of baby stuff ever since they
welcomed in their beautiful first child
so they made these baby onesies that
says I'll take you with me which if you
don't know is a is a heart it's a it's a
reference to not reference or to
reference one of his songs called take
you with me all about how like when
you're a kid you just want your parents
to take you with them and then when
you're a parent all you want to do is
take your kids with them I know it's
Jackie's favorite song so it was like a
layered thoughtful really cute gift that
I had like waited two weeks for it and
then when it ordered I'm like damn this
is really small and the tag said 12
months I'm like why the [__] did I order
that he's literally like two years old
yes so that didn't work out but I hope
Levi enjoys his new onesie but no with
honestly with kids it's actually not
what you said it's not like you could
just wear anything because like I feel
like with adults if you're hot you know
you suffer through it or you take your
sweater off like he needs to be dressed
perfectly I don't want him sweating I
don't want him cold I don't want him
getting sick like it's a very delicate
balance I don't want him getting
sunburned so if his arms are gonna be
like you have to you really have to
dress for the weather with these babies
no and Harry has what our you know
ancestors would call Milkha dick skin
porcelain looks like milk you know it's
like so sensitive I guess all baby skin
is sensitive now yeah yeah not me making
everything about her no it's like the
same way like a baby couldn't have like
a bath that's as warm as a bath that you
would enjoy because their skin is like
thinner
so true anytime I've ever bathed Harry
or any of the children lukewarm the
chili Luke white chili warm
vanilla just referencing back something
I said before uh can we also talk about
really quickly how children's clothing
sizes make absolutely no [__] sense
like anytime I'm buying a gift for a kid
it's like okay you know zero to six
months six to twelve that I can get you
know okay 3T 4T what the [__] is that
three-year-old four-year-old
okay but like a three-year-old who's
like you know a three years in one month
versus like a three-year-old she's like
three years in eight months
um well they don't grow as rapidly in
the threes like if you look at pictures
of Michaela from like I think I know she
looks the same people do complain about
children's clothes sizing I really
haven't found it to be so confounding
like I I I'm pretty straightforward and
if you have a big kid you size up in
general you should size up because it's
drinks in the wash they grow quick and
they'll grow into it
no that's the thing like whenever I'm
buying gifts for Brian's son Dean you
know Brian is six seven Jackie his baby
I know you haven't seen him in a while
he's as big as Harry and he's like he's
the same age as Levi right so you just
size up like I don't think I've ever
successfully bought like a friend of
mine or a sister of mine a gift for
their child that was the right size
okay here's the the pro tip size up even
if you got Harry an outfit that was 3T
like that wouldn't fit him today or
tomorrow but eventually it would but
what's the point in buying a gift for
the favorite baby in your life if they
can't wear it immediately and like you
can't take a thousand pictures okay well
if you want to wear it immediately and
you really don't know what you're doing
just ask the mother for the size but
then what's the point of a gift it's
supposed to be a surprise so then ask
the father
that's a good call that's see that's
helpful advice Jax ask the father
I'll take you in me not me making like
you know children sizing about myself I
you wouldn't expect anything less dirty
you know what oh my God I just had the
best idea for a patreon episode okay
Claudia trying on Harry's clothes
okay rude no you okay we come up with
like a list you come up with a list of
topics okay random obscure topics and
the challenge is I have to talk about
each topic until I can make it about
myself oh that's so good and I'll tell
you the episode will be three minutes
long like I don't have a problem like
let's do a prep trial run you'll be able
to rise to the occasion yeah throw me
like a crazy random topic a crazy random
topic
um
okay
betting
I mean
so easy first of all who spends more
time in bed than me and the importance
of betting can't be understated I also
have a podcast I don't know if you guys
have heard of it it's called the toes we
talk about like betting a lot and
actually one of our you know primary
sponsors is a company called bowling
Branch um highly recommend use co-host
okay that was really easy yeah betting I
mean Hello he's looking around when she
Lou okay but like bedding like I'm
looking around I've been put on the spot
Construction
I mean my life is literally dictated
about construction oh my God literally
last night this isn't construction see
look I already did it
um but I don't want to spoil it because
it's all documented in the Vlog that I'm
putting up today on patreon but last
night me and Margo went to
um the Summer I Turned Pretty Premiere
party like the whole cast was there we
got Glam we looked so stunning if I do
say so myself so I'm not gonna like
spoil what happens in the Vlog but I
guess I didn't even know the president
was in town yesterday and I had to go
all the way downtown I had the craziest
[__] Uber driver Jackie and like I'd
been in the car for 20 minutes and I'd
gone three blocks like and if I wasn't I
was wearing the most uncomfortable shoes
I was like thinking about taking the
subway but honestly I don't think I
could have made it in those shoes I
probably would have just went home
um
I don't want to spoil it but I had like
a scary incident in an Uber last night
like I'm not uh scared or like put off
by road rage I totally understand road
rage I have road rage my husband has
road rage but this was like another
level I was sending you guys videos
because I was like should I get out like
am I in danger or is like just the
traffic cop in danger
yes I look forward what did you think
seeing the Vlog to be honest the videos
that you sent I do not feel like they
captured the
the feeling what you were feeling
because it just felt like you know like
a New York driver like hey get out of my
way I've been driving longer than you
yeah but he wasn't like that's classic
Yellow Cab Driver energy like if you're
a yellow cab driver isn't yelling at the
traffic cop like he's not doing a good
job this felt like a little scary like
he just seemed like a little like off I
don't know he was really freaking me out
but maybe I was just being dramatic
you you would never no no not a turdy
Lou no but I don't want to diminish your
experience trauma
so I'll watch the blog and see for
myself you know and experience it as you
did well I'm not going to put any of the
footage of the driver I was just sending
that to you guys like to be like should
I get out oh and the other reason that
made it scary that I feel like people
don't talk about in a Yellow Cab or like
any type of regular car if you're in the
back seat like and even if the doors are
locked you know you pull the lock up and
you can get out but he had a Tesla and
they don't have that in Tesla is that
like kind of freaks me out I didn't
realize that yeah locking and unlocking
the doors it's also um the car does it
automatically there is a button like on
the screen but no for a passenger like
you're kind of
yeah like I always think whenever I get
into an Uber like if anything happens
like if this guy kidnaps me or even a
Yellow Cab especially a lot of the
Yellow Cabs are old you literally pull
the lock up you know that little hack
for when you were a kid but there wasn't
anything to help me but he wasn't
locking me and he ended up being fine
and he was like chatty and once we got
out of the presidential traffic it was
fine but um it was you know like he was
scary but also Tesla aside some of these
newer cars the lock goes down and it's
like yes so far down you can't pull it
it's flush with the door it's flush
yeah I feel like that's you know that
shouldn't be regulation for for like a
uber Lyft taxi car but it's hard because
it's like okay that makes it unsafe when
you are in an Uber but if you're a child
you can't open the door unlock it and
let yourself out like
their children there's hazards either
way
the children you have to think of the
children Claudia no and I constantly am
and I believe it was Jenna Maroney who
once said I believe the children are our
future
that was a hot take
that the children are our future
literally I know it's highly debatable
[Laughter]
we've got a great show this is an audio
only Extravaganza which we love a little
summer Friday energy totally um the
stories you were telling me before
they're not you know like groundbreaking
but I feel like those I say this every
time I feel like those types of stories
make the best episodes yeah we're just
kind of rounding out the week some
things are follow-ups some things are
just you know what's in the Zeitgeist
and I look forward to discussing with my
favorite swirly and between you know my
book club the Summer I Turned Pretty I'm
so behind on my TV I haven't watched new
Kardashians and I haven't watched the
new sex in the city
um and I will I will be doing that okay
I watched the new Kardashians last night
and it was like
it on the whole exact was watching with
me he hadn't seen it yet and like he
wasn't loving this season I'm like it's
not about the story lines like there's
so much tea like in the in between of
what's going on that like you have to
like watch between the lines a little
bit but I actually came up with a really
good example of the Dolce gate Saga and
like how would you feel like like in our
family in our family oh okay go okay so
I got married at the Pierre right yeah
my whole wedding was like it was a PR
weekend like very Eloise like New York
old New York like I was just like I mean
the difference is they didn't like pay
me to have it there I paid them but
whatever like you know I really like
that was like really my whole you paid
that that was like my whole wedding Vibe
was like the aesthetic aesthetic you
know that was
a big part of zacchio so say I had my
wedding at the Pierre they like loved
having the family there and they it was
really good for them and then a few
months later like they wanted to make
you the face of the Pierre and do like a
whole like Eloise at 30 at the Pierre
Vibe and like you were gonna be their
new like spokesperson space sounds
amazing okay sounds amazing like yeah
would I be allowed to be like have some
feelings about that by the way if it
happened now I feel like you wouldn't
have feelings about it if it happened
four months after right yeah four months
after the wedding yeah because now it's
like yeah that sounds awesome why
couldn't I do that but but four months
after the wedding six years yeah I know
I'm like is this [__] seriously saying
she would be mad right now
if the Pierre calls I'm answering right
no four months after the wedding like
I'm riding the eye of my wedding you
can't talk about my wedding without like
talking about the Pierre and they like
loved working with our family so much
like that they want to make you the face
of the pier I get it I know it I that's
a good example
and now and I'm not saying that you
shouldn't do it and I don't think anyone
was saying Kim shouldn't do it but
Courtney's like allowed to have some
feelings about it
it's fair because in a perfect world
like it would be her
right and in a weird way like it should
have been but
and you know what like like it could
have been I guess like she's not fashion
girly like Kim's whole life and I feel
like over the last few years like her
Mission even though she's accomplished
so many things has been to be taken
seriously to be a fixture in the fashion
Community to be given respect so and
Courtney doesn't care about stuff like
that Courtney doesn't go to Fashion Week
like Courtney doesn't care
um but like I guess it could have been
Courtney but like it wouldn't have been
so major
yeah but it's like it actually would
have been I mean it could have been
Courtney it would have been very
different but it also would have been
very like congruous it was like
Courtney's wedding and then it's like
the wedding looks and here's all the
other Synergy it would have been a lot
of synergy no I totally get it I can't
wait to see I know that the girls in
this episode actually like sit down no
they don't so they've said in next
week's in like last week they said next
week's episode like we're getting the
conversation between Kim and Courtney
there was no conversation they talked
about having a conversation Kim I mean
Courtney Chloe and Simon did and then it
looks like next week the story is kind
of over and I think that they cut the
convo well because I saw footage like
that was being um teased in a trailer
they were in Kim's bedroom sitting on
Kim's bed we did not get that scene in
this episode and last week they said we
were getting that scene
that means like it's still unresolved
yeah
damn no something and then I saw a bunch
of people on Tick Tock clipping just
like different not like major storyline
moments from the episode but like you
know if you it's like the subtext of it
subtext of these episodes is really
interesting even the fact that they had
a huge um birthday thing for Kim she had
a birthday dinner that Chloe plan and
then the next day like Chloe and the
crew like the mom crew that they're all
friends with um we're going to Vegas to
see Usher and like Courtney wasn't there
I'm sure she was invited but like why
doesn't she hang out with them
well you know they're in like such
different places like I feel like
Courtney's in her like nesting
especially now that she's pregnant but
like her you know newlywed stepmom
Blended life and Courtney and Courtney
and Kim especially Kim it's like Kim's
getting out of like a big marriage she's
like free woman single girl era like it
really is such different places in your
life for like a woman who's 40 you know
yeah but the thing is it was it was just
a an evening a night and the night
before they were at Kim's birthday
dinner so they're in town it's just a
few hours like the kids are already
asleep like if she like it's just like
they're not hanging like friends like
they used to yeah I also feel like
Courtney's probably in a place right now
with her marriage because it's like so
new and they're so honeymoon where she
doesn't want to do stuff without her
husband and that was clearly like a
girl's night right yeah and I do think
most of those girls are single right you
know we've all been there like you don't
want to leave like I get it yeah but
like we're okay if you were like taking
a PJ I know that's not a big deal for
them to like Vegas like if it's me shut
up like I'm oh Ben something's happening
and you're not invited see you later
smell you like I don't no I don't even
need to like vet it I'm like oh we're
flying Frontier here I'll be there
literally and it was like a really cute
evening that she had planned but then
they couldn't land the plane because of
the wind so they had to go back to LA
and they went to In and Out
it sounds fun too yeah also fun yeah
um okay well I'm gonna watch that and
all the TV I missed I'm gonna catch up
this weekend and programming update we
are back from July 4th weekend on
Wednesday so you will not have toast
Monday Tuesday I don't think people will
care because I think I think the
corporate girlies might be working
Monday but they're definitely not
working Tuesday they're definitely not
working Tuesday no oh also follow up
from yesterday's episode where we like
talked endlessly about holidays and
dates and how exciting next year is
going to be because July 4th is on a
Tuesday this year and that means next
year it's going to be on a Wednesday
thus giving us like pretty much the
entire week off
um not true actually next year's leap
year so it's a Thursday
I think that's better I think with the
one take we could have fallen into a
really bad place where we're working
Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday
and it's like oh you know what that's a
very good call right and I think with
Thursday it's sure fire we have a four
day weekend and you know what let's not
get greedy
you're kind of in you're putting a
positive spin on a negative situation
era like you keep doing that and I'm
living for every moment of it so I think
this is a really good thing plus a leap
year exciting
eh not really but I'm trying to put a
positive spin so true and but think
about like babies who are born on leap
day you're kind of like in recent years
kind of in your no not in recent months
like in your bed rest era giving Alec
Baldwin when he cameo'd on friends and
he's like toxically positive I I feel
like people would say the opposite of me
right now like I don't know either era
no no maybe a few months ago you were in
your hater era and I can respect and
relate to anyone in their hater era
because I can stoop as low as anyone
else
but now I feel like every time you're
telling me stuff like you're you're like
changing my mind like when I'm being
negative you're literally about to call
the Long Island Expressway a concrete
Miracle you know well forgive me for
trying to put a positive spin on a
negative situation that's so true I just
want to say like for me I'm just always
you know saying what comes to mind like
I don't feel like I'm in a positive era
or a negative at any given time if
anything I would think I would be in
like a negative
era one right now right now but I guess
you're saying I'm positive so I'm
positive but like I hate everything
you do you know like I hate television
but that's not it you're definitely
still like being toxically negative when
it comes to recapping I don't think I'm
being toxically negative like I sit down
to these television shows looking to be
entertained like I'm not looking to be
made upset and feel like my time has
been wasted so
I feel like so glad you brought that up
what we need to talk about what happened
like I don't know when I said it like a
week ago maybe maybe it was at the
beginning of the week you know I have no
concept of time I just was recapping a
show that I had heard about you know
everyone was talking about the bear yeah
and I said that I didn't think it was
very good and the way of like people
like there was like a wave of like talks
first of all of hate like first of all
people started leaving reviews I can't
believe they said they didn't like the
bear people then like took it as like
well clearly Claudia wouldn't like the
bear she's so privileged she couldn't
possibly understand what it's like to
work in Food Service what like it's
literally a TV show like the people who
like stand the bear were triggered like
it was giving former toaster like 2019
energy like it was psychotic you guys
like I'm allowed to not like a show and
it doesn't mean well Claudia obviously
doesn't respect people who work in food
service so it makes sense are you
kidding me no it's really crazy and you
never know when you're just gonna kind
of like step on a land and like what
shows just have these
cult toxic that can't handle a different
opinion
right and I didn't say that people I
didn't say that people who work in Food
Service don't deserve respect acting
like it's a documentary about oh yeah
service industry it's not a real
restaurant oh and then speaking of
totally random I saw a tweet last night
I have not been able to stop thinking
about share
Jeremy Allen White
is the work wait hold on wait I don't
want to [__] it why don't you search it
and I'll just copy it by saying like
whatever you're about to say like it's
not going to mean a lot to me because I
don't know him
okay fine but someone does yeah everyone
does Jeremy Allen White is the working
man's Timothy chalamet
okay and it's such a good call if you
like know about his previous roles and
just also the way that he looks because
like you know Timothy chalamet is very
like highbrow actor French Vibes you
know he wears like little culottes and
loafers and Jeremy Allen White is like
very you know high high profile actor
like does these really you know serious
acting roles but he's always playing
like a working man you know yeah usually
based in Chicago I thought it was a
great call great yeah just wanted to
share that with anyone who might care I
love when there's a great call that
Jimmy just sums up a situation
and like puts your thoughts into words
yeah yeah you know
um okay
so I guess without further Ado yeah
let's get into the past five stories
that you need to know
in the past five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by Lululemon
Lululemon and specifically Lululemon
shorts were made to stretch flex and
support the infinite ways of working out
giving you the courage to LEAP into
something totally new and totally
unexpected so Lululemon we know is the
go-to destination for everything this
summer but specifically shorts because
they are all made to last they're made
super well we love the hottie hot short
which is their short with a comfortable
range of motion and a really flattering
fit they allow you to Max your stride so
you can move freely with confidence the
lightweight Swift fabric lets in airflow
so you can move around without any sweat
without any baggage it's designed to
Wick away sweat before you even notice
it's there you can also carry your
Essentials in the two perfectly placed
very discreet looking Pockets also we
love the Wonder train short which is
their short with a supportive stretch
that keeps you dry it's powered by
everlux fabric so the Wonder train
collection manages heat and sweat so
you're staying comfortable and focused
the material is sweat wicking quick
drying it absorbs moisture and Wicks
sweat away during the most intense
training or you know just the most
intense sweaty day you know some of us
aren't training but we're still sweating
they also have great short shorts for
men the pace breaker short is versatile
the lightweight fabric means that you
can train move and stretch how you want
to without the baggage the Secure
Storage means that you can keep things
close without feeling everything bounce
around so it's that time of year we got
to be investing in good shorts because
we're sweating we've got creases and
crevices Galore down there so get into
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-u-l-e-m-o-n.com lululemon.com I've
been loving their shorts during this you
know undercarriage season you know what
I'm saying um
today's episode is also brought to you
by BarkBox which is so exciting because
BarkBox is a brand new sponsor and I've
been a BarkBox subscriber since the day
Thea walked into my life and he
literally just walked into my life hi
Angel man
um let me think I got the O in 2017 and
I think before he even arrived I had
subscribed to BarkBox because I had
heard so many fabulous things about it
BarkBox is a monthly themed box of
original toys delicious treats and
Unleashed joy every box is tailored to
your dog's unique needs and personality
and it's designed to make them happy
BarkBox is made by bark the dog obsessed
company with one goal make dogs as happy
as they make us and playtime isn't just
for pups it's for our pup parents too
every BarkBox is designed to bring dogs
and their humans together opening your
monthly BarkBox becomes a special
tradition for the whole family it's also
hard to beat the value and convenience
of BarkBox you know if you're a dog
parent you constantly have to be buying
new treats because they eat them all new
toys because they destroy them the
BarkBox is such a convenient thing
whenever it comes Theo literally dies
and the themes are so cute like on
Valentine's Day Theo got like a
valentine box it was so cute and you
know he doesn't have a girlfriend right
now he's kind of like between partners
so it really made him feel seen it was
giving galentine's day energy honestly
on every theme they like partner with
like different movies and they'll do
like different themed it's the cutest
thing and then you actually like
logistically don't have to buy treats
every month don't have to buy toys every
month and it's just nice to have it
because I'm constantly cycling them out
you know I have to throw away the ones
that Theo destroys
and BarkBox we're kind of new to BarkBox
and I realized I needed to get it
because Harry has so many toys and like
Bruno does not have that many toys as
Harry does and he always wants to steal
his choice so I got Bruno on BarkBox I'm
like you have your things your brother
has his things and Bruno is just in
heaven and now of course Harry wants
Bruno's toys sign up now and BarkBox
will double your first box for free
that's twice the toys treats and chews
and so to start to start spoiling your
dog visit barkbox.com toast that's a
really good that's a good sponsor I'm
excited about that yeah Bruno's right
here and he's like wagging his tail he's
like Mom you killed it you've killed the
F you killed the ad mom
are you ready for our next story our
first story our yeah I'm not ready for
the next one in no particular order
today I would say okay but I would say
some big news of the day is that Olivia
Rodrigo's new single vampire is here and
she's spilling the tea and talking about
how it's helped her with feelings of
regret and anger so her single vampire
and the video are out now she posted on
Instagram I made it with my very
talented and wonderful friend writing
this song helped me through lots of
feelings of regret anger and heartache
it's one of my favorite songs on the
album and it felt very cathartic to
finish I'm so happy it's in your hands
now and I hope it helps you deal with
any blood suckers in your life
yes so um highly anticipated second
album she just announced it's called
guts and she's clearly going for like a
four-letter Motif you know sour guts
um and the first single off of it just
came out last night I listened to it
once you know she's got away with words
she's a very talented Lyricist like she
gives kind of pop punk energy like Casey
Musgraves vibes
oh I was I wasn't getting Casey
musgrave's eyes but you know what I was
I mean I'm sorry just in terms of like
her her actual writing not anything
having to do with like the beat got it I
actually I was listening I listened to
vampire once very nice I liked the beat
and the lyrics were obviously very
pointed and personal but I was listening
to Kelly's album again and again and
some of her songs were actually giving
me like Olivia Rodrigo Vibes because I
guess they're both like you know pissed
woman yeah you know and they've both
been like taken advantage of they should
collab honestly they're in kind of the
same era but like Kelly's like the
the millennial version of gen Z's Olivia
Rodrigo that's actually a very stunning
comparison and I I like that a lot I
also fell down a rabbit hole um
specifically on Liz Heights Instagram
story where people were just trying to
break down like what this song is about
and I think immediately people went to
her ex-boyfriend whose name is escaping
me because he's not like super famous
um because you know she writes about
love but there is this like Theory
floating around that perhaps the song um
could be about Taylor Swift and Olivia
Rodrigo's like kind of fractured
relationship
we don't have any confirmation that it's
fractured but there's weirdness going on
I don't think it's that you know there
is like a lyric that feels like a direct
response to a lyric from an old Taylor
Swift song because maybe I could build a
castle out of all the bricks they threw
at me there's a you know a lyric about
you know bricks in a castle it's a
stretch for sure but I'm I'm loving the
journey I don't know it felt very much
like about an ex-boyfriend and how all
the girls called like said that he was
something and she said thought they were
crazy you know like it just it felt I
feel like people are looking into it too
much also I saw that it was released
today which would have been their
two-year anniversary yes I'm going in
the direction of that guy also because
he she's a he's a blood sucker Fame
[__] I guess if you're feeling really
nasty you could say that about Taylor
yeah no that doesn't apply
to Taylor
no no on its face it sounds like
something you would say about like a
cloud-chasing boyfriend but whose name
we literally can't even remember right
now because he's not even famous right
but like maybe we could do some mental
gymnastics to make it about to get there
I don't know I would call Taylor a blood
sucking Fame [__] and I also think if
she wrote a song about like the
dissolution of her relationship with
Taylor it would come more from a place
of like sadness and disappointment then
anger anger regret yeah by the way I
don't want it to be about that I'm just
like you know some people moved have
moved on in their life like I think
daily about like what the hell happened
between those two like they were so fast
and so Furious and then silence
and then there was that whole thing
about how you know she sampled New
Year's Day in one of her songs on sour
it happened with a bunch of her songs on
sour where she like referenced either
lyrics or Melody and she didn't properly
credit like Haley um Paramore what the
hell is her name why am I playing games
thank you
Haley Williams and then she you know had
to afterwards you know put proper
credits and give list them as
songwriters and you know give them
publishing rights so there was like a
little weirdness there even though at
first we were like oh that's such a
sweet nod to you know her Inspirations
but they weren't properly credited and
there was a kind of like a legal thing
with the with the labels so there's just
like a lot I thought the Paramore thing
it was like an accident like this song
just happened to sound a lot like
so much so that she had to list them as
songwriters
and then with Taylor I believe she like
sampled the piano
Melody from New Year's Day off the
reputation album and it also wasn't
properly like sourced and credited got
it that's messy and like there was like
where's your record label like this is
an amateur hour no there was something I
don't think they were expecting actually
they were but I just think I just think
like I'm
I believe they're smoke you know I don't
think I'm being dramatic I feel like
it's not that surprising I I because I
feel like Taylor like meets people gets
really excited about them and then you
know people go on with their lives and
yeah but then like they're like 10 years
apart like what are they going to be
doing together but then if you if you
really did like want to keep looking
into it like you know shortly after
Olivia Rodrigo's album Taylor did Red
Taylor's version where she released a
deeply personal song called nothing new
and it wasn't really it was not about
Taylor it was not about Olivia Rodrigo
it's about the whole concept about you
know as a woman in the industry like
growing and getting older is like your
biggest fear because you're not going to
be the shiny and new thing and in the
bridge of that she sings
I know someday I'm gonna meet her it's a
fever dream the kind of Radiance you
only have at 17. she'll know the way and
then she'll say she got the map from me
I'll say I'm happy for her then I'll cry
myself to sleep and they're like it's
about this you know hypothetical ingenue
the next big thing in pop he'll come up
to Taylor and be like oh my God
everything I could do because of you and
Taylor will like be happy for her but
she'll also hate her and it does kind of
fit the profile of like Olivia Rodrigo
but it doesn't feel pointed it's not
pointed
yeah and she did say she was happy for
her and then maybe she cried herself to
sleep
right like you know they're constantly
pitting women against each other in this
industry you can there's gonna be like
one you know famous woman at a time
no that's not true but okay okay okay
there's so many we talk about every day
instead of another famous woman like
Laura okay we only talk about I mean
we're also just like
you know women who support other women
but we literally only talked about
famous women that's true it's true
um all I'm saying do you think to say do
you think Olivia Rodrigo is the next
Taylor Swift
hmm what you know me actually like maybe
a few years ago I would have said that
like
but I think the next Taylor Swift is
Taylor Swift like she's bigger than
she's ever been like I don't I don't
even look past Taylor you know yeah
somebody asked me that the other day
I forget what I said
I had like three cocktails and I gave a
bad answer I think I said like Casey
Musgraves what did they ask you they
were like okay well like you know who
who's like the next big up and coming
like who's gonna be as big as Taylor
because that was I was we were all like
drinking and I was like playing Taylor
for everyone being like toxic like and
then she says this just trying to make
them understand because I think one of
the guys at the dinner I was at was like
look yeah like well she knows is Right
songs about like heartbreak and I just
had to like give him a whole [__]
lesson you know and I was being toxic
and I made everyone come back to my room
and put music on and gave like a full
lesson and you know what it was really
impactful and then he was asking
questions he was like wow I was so wrong
and he was like well who do you think he
got really involved so I think it was a
successful like he said Casey Musgraves
Jackie I was really like I had had like
maybe four or five Margaritas because
you want to know who I think it is
hmm not necessarily the next Taylor
Swift but we're always like you know the
next like Carrie Underwood and it's
always like we've been saying Kelsea
ballerini for 10 years and that's just
like they're just two different people
right I think the next big
country export is Megan moroney
you mean to cross over into pop yeah and
just like to to go all the way
I think it's a little too soon to tell
with her honestly no it's too soon to
tell that's why you call it now because
if we could tell then like it wouldn't
be a call it'd just be stayed in the
damn facts
harsh but facts
so that those are my that's what I was
thinking like I follow her on Instagram
her stories just like give off like you
know Taylor 15 years ago like doing
these shows in her dresses and like
seeing these it's actually true that she
wrote from her heart but I also think
there's just like so much more to pull
from over the next like 10 years
that's fair call it's fair call so that
I'm just gonna put that out there
put it out put it in the book
anyways check out vampire
um
Olivia is not happy no
are you ready for our next story
Raquel Levis is finally in talks for
Vanderpump Rules Season 11 return says a
report Raquel is finally in talks to
return to the show is filming resumed
earlier this week according to a report
the reality star that has been at the
center of scan of all drama that
propelled the show to new heights is
reportedly negotiating with Bravo on a
deal to return to season 11. sources
tell TMZ that talks haven't been all
that smooth though as several insiders
report of complications in sealing the
deal
yeah I mean I think it would take
first of all they really need her they
really need her
um I feel you know
like I'm straddling the fence of wanting
to be entertained but also being like a
human being with sympathy and feelings
and knowing that this is like the wrong
place for a girl in her State
um I do think though the tides
will turn and have turned and I don't
think the girls will attack her as much
as they have been I think they felt a
little bit of the fans being like all
right like calm down a little bit
especially after we saw her break down
so I don't know they need her in order
No One's Gonna film with Sandoval
yeah I I think like I don't even think
Tom Schwartz would at this point like
he's so concerned with Saving Face I
don't really know how the show moves
forward without her or at least this
storyline if we want to continue talking
about this yeah I think it would move on
we'd move on from it faster even though
Sandoval will always be on the show and
it will just be about him the girls
aren't really going to want to film with
her either like maybe Sheena would do
one more Scene like talking about the
Betrayal and the restraining order but
it is kind of a dead end I hope that if
she does go back to the show she demands
so much money yeah that maybe she could
just do one more season and then go into
like TV reality TV retirement which is
where I think she should be yeah and I
also think Bravo should really give her
whatever she wants in terms of her money
they need her because they want to like
keep milking the skin of all cow and
they really can't do that without both
of them no and the scandival has
absolutely brought Bravo back from
almost the dead like I think there was
like a like
there was a period where it was just
like the ratings were so down especially
for this show I don't think whatever
she's asking for could be too much no no
do you see the the caliber of
advertisers by the finale like you have
right I think that like you know when we
think about the highest paid women on
Bravo we think of like Denise Richards
doing four season two seasons for four
million dollars I think like Teresa Lisa
Vanderpump at one point like the most
you can really get Ramona was a million
dollars for a season and I don't think
that's a lot of money like give it to
Raquel yeah I wonder if they would give
her more than the highest paid cast
members because I think right now the
highest paid cast members are Katie and
Tom Sandoval and Sheena yep yeah like
the original principal characters who've
been getting raises every year yeah
that's true like how does Raquel like do
this horrible thing and then end up
getting paid more than everyone else
including Ariana
yeah I don't know get being paid more
but maybe she could get on equal footing
with them because she's what probably
one of the lowest paid cast members
she's only been a main character for
like three years but I just want to say
I don't think getting paid the same as
like whatever Katie's getting paid is
enough for her to put herself through
this again that's the thing I think I
have to imagine at this point the OG
principle characters can't be making
more
then maybe forty thousand dollars an
episode
okay let me get my calculator because
they do what like 22 Episodes
I don't know
yeah I think they do 40
000 times 22.
almost a million dollars it's 880.
she can't negotiate her
for me too but it would just then be
crazy that she would be the highest paid
person on the cast when she's really
been on it the shortest she is in the
wrong you know yeah um it's interesting
like she's getting rewarded for bad
behavior but honestly at this point I
feel like she's been through so much
like give her the money yeah and it's
entered it's television like you know
it's not the moral
you know like it this is how it works
you get rewarded for bad behavior I do
think she's been punished thoroughly
enough yeah um
and if they want her to put herself back
in what is not a good situation for her
mental health then that's gonna cost you
know you know what Jax I agree it's
economics
it's simple math yeah
well I do selfishly want to see her on
the show but like as as like a woman and
a human being like I actually really
fear for her
yeah and I also would be okay with like
moving on from I personally feel
ready to move on from Scandal I know I'm
probably in the minority in that like
you know all the Bravo accounts like
everyone's still living for like every
morsel of tea that comes from it like I
would be fine moving on from it like
accepting the season for what it was
which was like a juggernaut of craziness
and then seeing like how the cast like
wants to rise to the occasion now that
they've expelled these two people it
ain't gonna happen but yeah you know
like I would be okay with that but I
don't think you're alone in that uh yeah
I am alone in that but that's just
a little bit about you that's just about
me I'm always alone turdy Lou Oh no I
got my turret I'm okay and I got
stressed
[Music]
are you ready for our next story a
little more TV news yes a little more
negotiating news because Vanna White is
in negotiations to remain on Wheel of
Fortune hosted by Ryan Seacrest
so Vanna White doesn't seem likely to
say goodbye to Wheel of Fortune just yet
speculation has been swirling swirly
twirlies regarding her future with the
popular game show following longtime
host Pat Sajak's announcement that he is
retiring after 41 Seasons followed up by
confirmation that Ryan Seacrest will
take over hosting duties first I never I
didn't get to the part in Wednesday's
episode where he talked about Ryan
Seacrest taking over what were your
thoughts well everyone we were saying
how everyone's like oh this is an
uninspired Choice yada yada but we
really felt like honestly it's a job for
a proper host it's a job you have for
life he quit Kelly and Ryan I have to
imagine that has something to do with
this
um I actually think it films in La so I
I think he actually could do this Wheel
of Fortune yes it's on every day but
it's not one of those shows it's filmed
in the matter of like two weeks for the
entire yeah they Bank the episode it's
not relevant topical stuff they don't
need to be filming every week so I
actually think his plate I know
everyone's like Brian go to sleep he's a
hard working person and I actually think
this fits into his schedule and I think
he is America's host and I think Pat
Sajak is a beloved figure and I think
Ryan Seacrest could be that so I'm here
for it even though it's like oh it's
like duh but we we had a longer
conversation about like what does this
mean for Vanna because this is clearly
ushering in like a new generation and a
new era of Wheel of Fortune does does
that mean Vanna gets the boot
and they bring on like an Instagram
model they're still talking about
keeping her I think the right way to do
it is to keep her with Ryan for a little
bit let us get used to Ryan and then
when Vanna wants to go to then make that
change I agree like it doesn't have to
be all of a sudden like this is a new
Wheel of Fortune it's like no Wheel of
Fortune like works really nice the way
that it is 41 Seasons that's [__]
crazy like let's if it ain't broke don't
try and fix it I agree I think it'll
make it a lot easier for the people who
you know tune in because they love Vanna
and Pat for the last 50 years I think
it'll be a much easier you know Changing
of the Guard transition if they do it 50
now 50 later yeah and I'm sure would
also be nice for Ryan to have someone so
seasoned there who can help him it'd be
nice though if him and Julianne Huff had
worked out and then Julianne could have
been the Vanna White yeah you know
dancing and sashaying to the letters
yeah I wonder who I mean that's an
amazing job when it does come available
that's Vanna White I feel like nobody
talks about how she has the best job in
Hollywood she's a household name
literally everyone knows her name she
doesn't have to do anything she doesn't
have to speak she doesn't like give her
opinions and get like you know canceled
for what her take is because she didn't
like the bear like she's winning Vanna
stays winning yeah so we need a model
who has
Pizzazz he's not really known for like
something that we're just gonna always
think of her as like something else no
honestly I I genuinely think a no name
who hasn't that's also the thing about
Vanna White she's like this different
cool Vanna White like you need someone
with a great name who can wear a dress
and not speak it's not
it's not a talent-based job it's like a
branding based job but you also have to
have like this Inner Light That Vanna
has this Inner Light this intangible
thing you can't just have like some
mopey model walking across the stage no
but you also need a model with a great
name I don't even know Vanna was a model
like you need
honestly in another life okay in another
life if things had worked out
differently for so many people this
would have been an amazing job for
Meghan Markle after she did Deal or No
Deal
she has this amazing name Meghan Markle
Vanna White like you know what I mean
she's got that they always say she has
that Markle Sparkle yeah yeah of course
she's you know above it now but if
things had worked out differently for
her after like suits and Deal or No Deal
this would have been the job for Meghan
Markle no you this is the best call
you've ever made no I can't believe I
actually made a good call because I make
the worst ones this is
what could have been yeah
no that's it case closed moving on I
mean you never know
no I think we do know I think we do know
I don't know what's next for them their
stock is plummeting I know it's like
everyone woke up one day and was like
we're done with them
yeah you know what I think the American
people
it's gonna be a hot take ready I think
the American people like an American
culture really respects hard work
and for this latest news where like
their podcast like you got 20 million
dollars and you had to sit down and
record episodes and like you didn't even
do that it's like damn do you know what
I would do for 20 million dollars
everyone's like come on
yeah wait did you read Barry Weiss had a
newsletter article about like the demise
of Megan and Harry and that's literally
what the author said that like oh really
that it's about their lack of hard work
oh my God I just want to say I subscribe
to Barry Weiss's newsletter I do and I
swear to God I did not read that I'm not
gonna lie like I said I support I like I
subscribe to support but like I'm not
they come so early in the morning I I
don't think I've literally ever read one
unless I just tell you one I'm like read
it [__] yeah but I don't read them
they're like very thought-provoking you
know me like I gotta avoid thought at
all I swear to God I just came up with
what I know I didn't I just needed like
that was literally the author's thesis
she was like you know um a Harry and
Megan Stan when everything happened and
then like just devolved into like
everyone sort of turned on them and her
thesis was like that it's the lack of
hard work
oh my God not me coming up with like the
same thought as like a a a thinker you
know as a thinker yeah I this is by the
way I'm two for two today like this did
I saved my life yeah
that's so funny but no um the podcast
stuff than not doing the interviews with
the non-famous people and that's what I
feel like we never clarified because
Andy was like no I did her I did when
you were off the show I said that like
it's entirely possible like what Andy's
saying is true and what this professor
is saying is true like yeah Megan didn't
think it was worth her time for this
non-famous person to interview and so
she dubbed her her vocals in that
episode but I believe Andy and I believe
that she sat down with Andy and Mariah
Carey and Paris Hilton yeah no it just
feels like in the last few weeks like
all this stuff like negative stuff and
people are just like talking so
negatively about them whereas like no
one would do that for the last few years
even dumwalik would posted like a thing
um and people are saying that their
marriage is suffering but I I don't I
feel like that's a little that's like an
easy low thing to say I don't actually
believe that but then Dumont posted a
blind like she never posts about Harry
and Megan I don't know if you ever
noticed that really I'm sure she gets so
many tips but she had said when she came
on the toast like it's just not worth
talking about them because their fans
are just like so vicious
sexist and racist but so she posted
someone right like a tip like Harry and
Megan aren't doing well and she was like
there's a lot of noise about this now
oh I don't I I see that on like these
Royal Tick Tock accounts I don't believe
it because I've watched a lot of what
they've put out and I had thoughts on
all of it but one of my always my major
takeaways like these are two people who
are deeply in love the same I agree and
and at this point
it would not behoove them to have
marital troubles like honestly no get it
together and at this point like
one of the biggest things that they have
is each other
yeah and by the way if they didn't I
think it would be so isolating for both
of them
I think if anything they're toxically
attached and dependent on one another
because they need each other like
they're so
removed from from even like Hollywood
they're they're too famous like they
don't go out to dinners and go to
parties like they have each other and
they live on these big pieces of
property and and they have that family
and I think that
I think that they they love each other
deeply and I think that they also really
need each other yeah I agree so I don't
think that I believe in their love like
I really do I do but I also could
imagine that having this like
professional trouble right now like
might put a damp and a damper on things
might be hard times but like I I think
they're very committed to each other I
don't think anything's coming between
them anytime soon me neither
are you ready for our next story a
little more TV news that I know that
you're upset about
oh my God I'm so [__] upset the other
two is ending at Max
amid what the [__] well so rumors it
might be these might be two separate
things happening but there have been HR
complaints so insiders say that the
shows no I literally I read the headline
and I threw my phone across the room
like I didn't even read this article so
they the it came out that the show was
ending literally last night's episode
was the last episode now insiders say
that the show's creators were the
subject of Staff complaints and a formal
investigation though ultimately cleared
of wrongdoing so these just could be
like two separate things that are
happening but the show being canceled
like does leave you with questions so if
this was the only thing that was
happening
I don't believe it's about HR no and
please do you know how many problematic
people are on television like these two
were actually cleared like there was an
investigation so it's like we're blaming
that but like you know whoever is on
every show and ever the idol did you see
what they were saying about what was
going on in the island please spare me
yeah I'm so upset and this doesn't feel
like you know every show we like nobody
likes and it gets canceled you know like
I get that I feel like everybody watches
this show like when I posted it on my
Instagram people I knew personally
message like toasters in the DMS
everyone is like what the [__] this is
like a show going out at its height I
think the first season in the second
season were like kind of quiet and then
people fell in love with the Show
recently and binge it like I don't know
why you would cancel a show with this
much momentum when you think about all
the crap on HBO do and just like that
next okay
no I agree with you I feel like now is
the time where it's been popping off and
it's also very respected like in in the
industry and even if you watch the show
like you can tell it's like there it's
kind of like
entouragey
oh yeah I guess but no like it's very
elevated like and they're it's very like
poking fun in itself so I feel like and
poking fun at the industry so I feel
like the industry would keep propping it
up because it's just like a funny
Industry Show No and like people in the
industry go on the show and play
themselves that's why it reminds me of
Entourage yes so something is definitely
I'm so [__] upset like my God I can't
have anything not to make it about me
but like come on now you know how I feel
it's no but like when when you love a
show and it gets canceled because nobody
watches it like let's be real not to be
rude and like at least okay yeah that
sucks but like just flipping it like at
least you have people to commiserate
with like when it happens
that's true but like this I'm just left
with confusion like you don't cancel
shows that do well
no
not unless like the main character wants
to go but there's like or somebody dies
yeah but I feel like they actually don't
cancel when somebody dies they just like
try and keep it alive yeah I'm just like
this is this sucks this is ruining my
July 4th
and no one's more upset about this than
Ben
I wonder if Zach knows yet because we've
been watching it yeah I think he's
caught up what was like nothing he
definitely has one more episode nothing
these days is like actually funny and
like really makes me giggle and I just
look we can't have anything no we but
you can have him just like that in the
idol though thanks so much thank you you
should start watching that thanks no
that's exactly the one that I wanted
good cause it's one you got actually
well I'm sorry that this is happening to
you I'm here
um if you need tools to help get through
now I'm kind of in like the denial phase
it's a good place to be
I'll stay here for a while it's also
hard to find that out like while you're
literally watching the show because like
say like the season ended and then in a
year and a half they're like it's not
coming back like it wouldn't feel so Raw
but it also feels like the rug was kind
of pulled out from underneath him and
however this season ended it's not how
the creators intended for the the story
and the characters lives to end for us
like
so they didn't even get to say goodbye
like at least you get when you know your
show is ending you get to say goodbye in
a meaningful way and like wrap up loose
ends I feel like they probably thought
they were going to be back in a few
months for next season and they didn't
finish right of course maybe on a
cliffhanger right
I'm sorry I'm like two episodes behind
and now I'm Gonna Save the [__] out of
them yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is just kind
of kind of debate new
ton okay because Heinz has sparked
debate on whether or not ketchup should
be refrigerated
what yep obviously it should condiment
enthusiasts are up in arms about whether
or not ketchup should be stored in the
fridge on Tuesday the Heinz UK Twitter
account tweeted the company's hard
stance on where the Tomato based
condiment belongs they said FYI ketchup
goes in the fridge okay because you know
what if they said that it didn't I would
be like ew I'm sure I'm sure that
ketchup is like full of preservatives
and if I left it in the pantry it would
be fine like but I don't need Heinz
telling me that because if they're
saying like it is you know shelf stable
when it's supposed to be fresh tomatoes
like ew
the commenters disagree they said no it
doesn't you stick to production and I'll
stick to consumption they said wait hold
on they said if it was meant to be in
the fridge they'd put it there at
supermarkets
no that's an amazing call no it's not
because so many things are refrigerated
upon opening
true tomato sauce every like so many
things they're shelf you know like good
call good call like it's sealed when you
get it you have to take that plastic cap
off I'm like so I obviously I want
people to sound off in the comments like
do you keep your refrigerator where do
you keep your ketchup I obviously keep
mine in the fridge nothing like cold
ketchup
obviously and it makes it makes it taste
so much better you're having a hot
french fry with a cold tomato ketchup
delicious delicious I can't believe this
is even a debate no and now that's why
they say on Tick Tock you can eat at
everybody's house like people do [__]
weird [__] that's a funny thing to say
but I also wonder if this is like a UK
thing because this has been like a big
combo amongst Heinz UK Twitter
perhaps
but it just goes to show you you can't
eat at everybody's house no
that's really true yeah I know like
people Stitch it like when they see
people you know people on Tick Tock will
be like come make dinner with me and
then they'll do something like really
gross and then people with Stitch and be
like that's why you can't eat at
everybody's house that's really funny
yeah and it's like people will um oh
like girls who are like clean my sink
with me and they just use hot water they
don't use like Ajax or anything and it's
like really gross you can't eat over
everybody's house
damn yeah so it's true like food is so
personal
so personal I can't believe there have
been people who have been putting their
it never even occurred to many to put
ketchup in the pantry another debate
question sound off what do you think is
more personal comedy or food
food
what do you think
I guess food
but like it's crazy how like two people
could watch a comedy especially when
like one person is cackling throughout
and someone else is like this is the
worst thing I've ever seen
no I'm now leading a little bit more
towards comedy because like it could
there be a meal put forth that someone's
like this is the best meal I've ever had
in someone else's like this is the worst
meal I've ever had I mean there are
people who like literally think
McDonald's is disgusting and I'm over
here thinking it deserves a Michelin
star yeah well that's facts like things
that you think are ubiquitous like
McDonald's like
I guess like there are people who don't
like french fries like to me that's like
the most basic kids love it adults love
it but there are people who don't like
it that's really crazy sickness I feel
sad for those people those people like
bring me great like I'm an empath so I
feel lots of sadness when I think about
them
this episode really makes me want french
fries and you know what like why not get
some McDonald's fries today
I don't know just let me know when
you're ordering and I'll I'll be on my
way are you gonna come over today
yeah I need to go shopping because I got
invited to a fabulous July 4th party
tomorrow so I want to wear something
like cute red white and blue but like
not like lame you know um
um so that's like on my list of things
to do today also I'm about to finish
editing the Vlog that I made last night
so by the time this episode goes up it
should be on patreon the Summer I Turned
Pretty Red Carpet Premiere blog on the
patreon did you get to watch the show
no I talk about it all in the Vlog I
thought it was like a screening I was
like literally I wore uncomfortable
shoes I'm like it doesn't matter like
I'm gonna be sitting and enjoying the
first episode I'm gonna get to see it
before everyone and it very quickly
occurs to me Margo and gbt who are the
stars of the Vlog that we are not
getting to see the first episode I don't
know why we all thought that they didn't
even say it in the invite because that's
what a Premiere is was it called to
Premiere in the invite
I don't know like you're getting chicken
wings and tailors Back to December okay
it's don't spoil the Vlog oh okay I
haven't I'm really excited to watch the
Vlog because I didn't even ask you about
your big night out but I really want to
know how it went but it's all in the
Vlog it's all it's all in the Vlog honey
put it on the Vlog
and you know what before the episode you
were like saying the stories were [__]
and like we'll just have to get through
this episode and this might be seriously
one of my favorite episodes maybe it's
because I made two really good calls but
um might be one of my favorite episodes
in the last two years should we call it
Claudia made two good calls
I just think the P honestly like I feel
like there are certain themes of the
toast and me making atrocious calls and
like bad takes and then you like
checking me that's kind of a major theme
here and so today like I was kind of the
thought leader of this episode and I
just think people should know you're
usually the thought leader and I'm
usually like the clown and I like that
those roles that we play I'd like that
Dynamic but it does feel good to be the
smart one and not that you were being
dumb but like I was being smart
I am really happy for you that you could
have that feeling and enjoy it you know
because I think the Smart's not cool
sometimes it sounds like we'll be smart
because this is our last episode for a
really long not a really long time till
Wednesday and it's Audio Only I think we
have the potential to reach number one
in comedy so if you're listening to this
and you have both Spotify and apple and
you're like I could listen to this
episode on either but they've actually
fantastic episode
[__] do you wanna I'm actually asking
you to go to Spotify and just put it on
mute and play it like I think I reach
number one oh [__] Apple [__] okay you
know what I said I was smart and now I'm
being dumb as [__] so we are ending the
episode while you're ahead thank you so
much for listening to the toast and
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found out Spotify iTunes Stitch your
public radio I read a castbox all the
places but we listen to podcasts find us
to toast lead to five star review about
how beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are have an amazing holiday
weekend happy July 4th
can you see love ya bye love you bye